oh man I'm out of the bedroom it's a hot
day it's hot hot hot hot I'm not even
wearing pants just to show you guys real
quick oh there it is
[Music]
hey what's going on here you [ __ ]
lazy [ __ ] I saw you kick that I son of
the frigerator you [ __ ] now I said I
wasn't going to do a video on this and
I'm not I'm actually not doing it about
this person or the event that really
happened but through this person's death
and an interesting conversation started
pop up between me and a lot of other
people and not just with me I'm talking
about over Twitter I'm talking about
over the instagrams
I'm talking about over book [ __ ] and as
you all know if you are keeping up with
this world xxx that xxx temptation and
just to put it out that I'm not fronting
the saying like I knew how to say the
man's name prior to this I look that
[ __ ] up
X X X s it's awesome
xxx times bad cause he owns like I'm not
even making a joke i legit thought he
was like Spanish or something x time
spent filming and then one of my friends
were like well you dumbass why don't you
just say his [ __ ] legal name instead
then guys are [ __ ] evil genius she's
like I don't want anybody to know how to
say my name before I passed away hot
Python on it and I had mentioned before
I'm only doing videos that interest me
and things that usually interests me
have to do with my human perspective now
the argument that started popping up
between everybody was do you respect the
man or do you respect the artist so the
controversy behind his personal life and
I don't need to tell you by this week
you guys probably already know is the
fact that his personal life
apparently he's a piece of [ __ ] people
brought up the fact that he's been
accused or it's been confirmed that he
beat the [ __ ] out of his pregnant wife
or girlfriend so bad that both her eyes
shut he also openly admitted to beating
up a prison [ __ ] as he would call it
and with that information people were
saying good riddance I'm glad he died
get him off the [ __ ] face of the
earth he's a piece of [ __ ] anyways who
the [ __ ] cares and there's the other
side saying like yo get off his [ __ ]
back I loved his music I loved his
[ __ ] art let me mourn the death of
this [ __ ] dude who cares if he did
that type of [ __ ] he was young people
make mistakes etc etc etc and just at
least two opposing sides people are
[ __ ] going at it saying
[ __ ] like he'd be a [ __ ] out of a
[ __ ] pregnant woman why the [ __ ] you
care so much he's still a young man I
don't understand why everybody's game
Heath everybody makes mistakes and a lot
of you guys wanted me to cover his death
and I'm not gonna do that but I am gonna
talk about this because this topic in
this controversy where people are going
at it is very interesting to me I think
there are two sides to this in the sense
that two people or two sets of people
who are arguing aren't really looking at
each other's side and there's really no
empathy
so let's talk about the side where
people are saying good riddance I'm glad
he's off the face of the years to [ __ ]
all of his face tattoos yeah [ __ ]
itches sketch face [ __ ]
and I guess for people who are on this
side saying that I'm glad he's off the
face of the earth and [ __ ] him or
whatever you're allowed to feel that way
you are a hundred percent allowed to
feel that way nobody can tell you how
you should feel about somebody else's
debt that's period in the story however
I do want people to think about it
through this lens as well it was 20
years old and I'm not saying that any of
the stuff that he did was excusable I'm
saying where the [ __ ] were you when you
were 20 now when I was 20 years old it's
not a great person I did not make smart
choices and I'm pretty sure there are
more than a handful of people that would
have looked at me and said you know what
dude I'm glad that fat slant-eyed
big-tittied [ __ ] I'm putting my
feelings is that I'm glad he died if I
passed away at that point and I'm pretty
sure that I was I wouldn't have really
been missed however through time life
experiences and a lot of things that I
did I I learned to grow the [ __ ] up and
I learned a change as a human being and
I became a better person not only
through this space but having
conversations with people and being able
to experience life as a [ __ ] adult
past the age of 20 a life was lost at a
young life at that and a life that
wasn't allowed to change wasn't allowed
to grow as a person and maybe people see
it as he's 20 years old he's an adult
and I 100% agree with you but some of
the biggest moments where I grew was
past that age past the age of twenty
twenty-one and all the way until I was
like 26 or 27 so what does that say and
there's the juxtaposing side to that
where people are saying like you know
what he was doing charity work he was
doing all this other stuff and he was a
good person because he did X amount of
things well here's the thing people just
because you do nice things after the
fact you do something terrible doesn't
erase the fact that you still did
something [ __ ] terrible it doesn't
take away the
guards that that woman has not from in
the physical sense but the fact that he
beat the [ __ ] out of that girl had her
eye swollen shut while she was [ __ ]
pregnant and could have killed that kid
it doesn't erase that way and when you
say stuff in his defense talking about
the other nice things that he possibly
did or was going to do it doesn't negate
everything that he's done in the past
especially when there's no apology for
it there's no evidence of growth that he
would do it again
there's no outline apology of her
beating up a prison [ __ ] as he would
call it and to your credit if you are
saying that you know what let's separate
the artist from the person let me just
enjoy their art a hundred percent
I [ __ ] agree with you it's okay to
feel sad about somebody who affected
your life in a positive way despite what
he did in his personal life you know you
took away what you did from that
person's art i'ma say it again if you
are saying that you are judging the man
by just his art then you should stick to
that side but when you start defending
somebody's actions his past and all the
bad things that he's done and saying
that it's okay because of all the new
things he's done that's where it gets a
little [ __ ] tricky let me give you an
example I mentioned this before I'm just
kidding news and maybe even on this
channel like Bill Cosby was a huge
influence in my life not not not not
that not that touchy touchy [ __ ] not not
I'm talking about The Cosby Show you
know cliff cliff cliff cliff he he's
constable people aren't gonna take away
the positive effect that The Cosby Show
had on me you showed me diversity it
showed me humor they show me a real side
to families that a lot of sitcoms were
not doing it was just a lot of dislike I
don't think Jimmy wants to go out with
me it was some real [ __ ] the very first
Cosby episode that I saw and I think it
was the first episode of the first
season
théo his son was sitting at at this bed
right and he was funny and he was
talking about like how bad he was doing
in school and how much he was [ __ ] up
and he just looks at his dad and his dad
was getting on his case about studying
and he goes dad why can't you just love
me for who I am and then Bill Cosby or
Heathcliff
comes up and puts his hand on his
shoulder and says that's a dumbest
[ __ ] thing I've ever heard in my life
that was a real moment in TV that I
don't think a lot of people saw in men
it definitely influenced you know the
comedian and the person that I am today
however you don't see me saying [ __ ]
like Oh Bill Cosby no he didn't he
didn't rape those 82 women it's a little
touchy touchy here little honk honk
there I mean he's touched no he's he
should go to [ __ ] jail a lot of
people are saying like would upload
whose legacy his legacy and I bring up
that example of mr. Cosby mr. Gela Putin
pause is because I truly believe that is
a version of respecting the art but
still judging the human being if
anything I don't know why this bothered
me so much and I don't know if people
are gonna bring this up but you know the
picture that I saw of this guy that was
slain and shot in his car
was like a snapchat or was like a
snapchat photo or some sort and the only
thing I think about that is a fun man
you see this [ __ ] human being dead in
a car and the first thing that you do I
mean you could have opened up your your
your video camera to record what was
going on as evidence or proof or just to
show what was going on in the crime
scene but instead you opened up snapchat
a social platform so you could show show
people that hey I caught expectation
dead in his car but man the world that
we [ __ ] live in is so weird and how
we prioritize things in life is [ __ ]
up and to see people without a social
app to post the death of somebody for
social currency instead of maybe calling
for help trying to help the human being
makes me think that you're a sick
[ __ ] person and society is kind of
sick in general but that's a whole
nother topic to get into and I really do
want to leave it up there for
conversation is that what do you guys
think I don't know man like I feel like
sometimes like we've evolved as people
but then I see something like this
something even this small like on
Twitter talking about the death of a
young rapper and I still see people in
society without empathy without love
without care for you
and it makes me sad that people could
celebrate the death of somebody that was
so young I don't know no matter how much
somebody's art has affected me
personally I can never stand there and
defend somebody who did something like
that or at the same time I could never
celebrate somebody's death who died so
young who had who has never given a
chance to evolve or become better than
that's just that's just me I don't know
what do you guys think
[Music]